et c'est ça qui est en jeu derrière ce
grand combat des plateformes ce n'est
pas qu'un combat économique ça n'est pas
qu'un combat financier ce n'est pas
qu'un combat pour l'emploi c'est un
combat pour ce que nous sommes comme
européen comme français comme allemand
comme portugais comme espagnol donc
défendre Deezer
ses défendre notre culture
ses défendre nos artistes ces défendre
notre mémoire c'est défendre notre
patrimoine musical
[Musique]
est-il vrai que la prime de Noël va être
reconduite la prime de Noël oui
vous savez ce que c'est la prime de Noël
alors moi je n'ai pas de prime de Noël
en tant que débuter en bas en tant que
député mais oui
mais eux
non là-bas moi je ne connaissez pas ça
là peut-être que vous me donnez les
[Musique]
informationsnel vous ne connaissez pas
la prime de Noël mais je vous dis que en
tant que député je ne vais pas recevoir
[Musique]
mais
qui s'appelle